hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the
things in the night okay so when I came
up here before I was in a bit of a hurry
because something was chasing me oh
hello Dennis
do you have anything on you that I could
use madam no okay
alright let me check my notes cuz let's
see I need looks for some corn oh I got
that need to look for some things to get
past the web so I can get in the portal
find my father and end this and the
firing rods is some old thing and need
to get into the restricted area and
someone said something about the drill
or the screwdriver was to get in a
certain door somewhere so that's
probably a good place to start
ah just like that well hot damn that's
not bad
good on you whoever commented that I
didn't I I read the comments but I I
don't always remember the names leg well
well I got not enough but oh well oh no
ah bing-bong I got it I got it
whoa it wasn't a chair but it'll do
chairs have been betraying me lately I
don't know if I trust them anymore
oh thank you so much okay just as an
engineer I want to know how this just
moved randomly too straight forward
there's nothing in the ground it's not
made of metal so no magnets it just
moved forward how's that impossible it
don't matter
wait a minute
fake fake out it's fake it's not real
it's a bunch of lies it's a web of lies
jump on your course anyway I got here
excuse me chair I'm gonna be nice to you
sir you'd be nice to me right not at all
Bing bong what do I do with that dr.
Stevens I've been helping dr. Finn with
his experiments but the other doctors
don't know about this dr. Finn has been
raising the dead but I failed him and
fear he's gonna going to do get revenge
on me plus he told me he had something
growing strong in the restricted area I
think we are all in danger here we came
to build a machine not to bring back the
dead this is insane I must get out
escape your fate doctor
dunker Stephens oh there's come from oh
whoa ah maybe I should try that door as
the screwdriver before can't get through
no look ah oh no you were there
nevermind it was there already okay
man I hate I hate that music more than
anything that music in the background
right now is just the worst okay that's
not okay about drill through it no okay
great Sonia okay so I'll try the drill
just got double check everything either
way I got a no I gotta finish the drill
so whatever that I need for the drill
for I got it and what I need that for is
not up here now this is where I came up
and got another drill part so not up
there not man these fires should give
off a little more light than that you
think oh hello come back here oh you see
Madonna that's not that important to me
I've got plenty of literally got 14
freaking things I love Don and him and
I've got plenty of tinderboxes but
there's nothing to use them on hey the
way it's fine
hello Justine this carry on
ah oh don't do that to me yeah nope okay
none of that back here I'm quite
remember I'm pretty sure that this is
all giving that there's more goop
appearing it's suggesting that I leave
this area and just go on my merry way
already been here and okay I go through
here ah yeah of course this door here oh
I guess if I click it before I need to
look for some tool to get this door open
huh maybe maybe this what whoa holy crap
how did that how did that do that ah
really
I spent all that time trying to assemble
that drill and it just breaks open on a
single door Wow what a douche door door
douche hear me door your dingdong dank
douche
I don't trust these closets once was
these mini drawers mini dressers that's
not right there's give each I need you
to step on you
yeah totally respectful and dignified
manner okie okay why they give all these
drawers if they don't expect to put
anything in them odd key another strange
key it's to the restricted area but it's
so strange okay I'm assuming this
signatory is that one door that went
straight boom I'll sneak up on me like
that
yeah no no can't blow it up okay alright
nevermind either way it's fine don't
worry about it I got this I'm out of
here
big like boom boom boom we pick down
arrow moving on into the science area
now I'm curious I'm actually curious um
oh no wait no yeah I'm just wondering
what the last object did I don't think
this is like going to at the end if it
is no it's not no no really no I thought
I thought oh I thought for sure that was
gonna be it all right the restricted
areas definitely got to be done this way
right probably probably you oh you're
the fire room I don't need to go in
there I just gotta find my way to the
restricted area
get in I'm pretty sure it is bound to be
down this way because this looks
particularly diabolical and also well I
mean I think there was a door at the end
of the hallway that I I mistakenly
I didn't I didn't mistakenly think who's
locked it was locked all right going
down the evaluator elevator
I'm almost suspicious that no monsters
have come out as of yet it's oh it's
it's odd it's hard but there has not
been okay you know no okay
must be at the end of this hallway at
least I think it is if it's not then I
made a terrible mistake and I have to go
back ah there it is that was it I
remember I remembered right yep winner
unless it's horrible in there then I'm a
loser
nice whoa hey whoa hey that ground
electrified what's the dealio here
you've been waiting for me a hook oh all
right I don't know if it was like the
right way to do this but I'm not gonna
risk anything and die maybe it's all
just nice oh it's all this ground
nevermind it's like invisible glass or
something I have come a long way
oh you have come a long way Finn isn't
this guy's name dr. Finn it's a bit more
okay come in Papa I'm coming
they even welcome to your death pin and
my rebirth thanks to your father walk on
earth once more and everyone in it will
die so you use my father and had him
kill all these people for what just so
you can walk alone in the world your
father live soon it will be the same for
you no I will kill you by blowing this
place back to hell and you together with
it I need to put the core nail on top of
the Machine and then strike it using
that hammer which hammer I'd like to
swing a hammer on top of what machine
this pink okay
Hammer hammer that hammer are you using
that hammer what hammer
oh this favor oh no ha ha ha you will
pay for this Finn you have received the
demons heart have i oh how did i have
get that half why did he laugh
I gotta go back and see oh it's just
came in okay never mind
Ron I have the demons heart soon I will
become am what loading screen man dad
that was a diaval now best soap it's so
cool
this is the interpretation of what is
going on in there
this is so cool by the way
all right where are you putting what
done oh wow thank you I didn't want to
have to walk through all that so thank
you for doing that
mm-hmm I think I'm getting very very
close to the end of this custom story
should be incredible hang on I know that
it's down there but he's going to see up
here what what was I'm here before I go
on with anything else okay
ah okay so if I go in here and I place
the demons heart in there then it will
most likely be the get me to the end
which means considering that I I like to
keep the ending all in one episode that
I'm gonna cut this just a little bit
early sorry to do that but I am
immediately gonna be recording the next
one so thank you all so much for
watching and as always we'll see you in
the next part
bye-bye